[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
number 71q and a
ama in the dna
so i wanted to say something about i
thought about saying it in the main live
stream but i forgot
that it is actually uh the birthday week
of all
four of our carnivorous here and you
can't see maddie at the moment but she's
lying on the floor here beneath us
between us
and we actually know her birthday her
birthday is
uh tomorrow yes she is going to be eight
maddie
because we knew her father did know her
father sailor sailor
and he was quite a sailor dog he was um
and tesla the dark the dark kitty in the
background
is 10 this month and the two youngers
are two this month they are not uh
littermates but they are both
they're from a feral cat colony in
ashland oregon
um so it is it is all their birthdays
right now
it's amazing yeah you're unimpressed but
well i
don't believe they know their names and
i i'm fairly certain they are
unaware of their birthdays
sorry
the only reason to talk about things is
if they're conscious of you talking
about them
no it's not like that i just um
i don't know
it's awesome all right um
here we go this uh we're starting with a
few questions from last week go to the
discard question and then questions from
last era before
finishing off with questions from this
hour hi you beautiful people so who's
going to illustrate that dr weinstein
original
in reference to the loose the seuss poem
i can imagine it already i love this new
outlier academia cathedral and i'm proud
to be a stone amongst cornerstones
may forums abound yeah i mean
let's put it this way i would love to
see that thing illustrated but there is
no part of me that imagines that that is
a
minor task right um so anyway yeah i
would love it if somebody
was was up for it and i you know as i
was
writing and i certainly did think about
the imagery that would go along with it
you did
sure yeah i don't i actually i don't
know how you write poetry
i don't mean i don't know how you write
poetry i mean i don't know how you write
poetry
well in fact you know i mentioned on the
uh last week's live stream that
it was a very quick process you know
there's hours and hours of like
going back and tinkering lines and
things like that but the basic
thing emerged very rapidly uh as did the
first
significant poem that i wrote and but as
it was emerging rapidly you were
visualizing it you were
imagining what the illustrations might
be yeah
yeah because in some sense i'm you know
that actually surprises me a little bit
because you're so
you're so auditory you're so sound based
yeah i mean i know there's definitely
something to that but uh
on the other hand i think you know i
mean the poem itself alludes to the fact
that soos is lodged deep in all of our
minds
and so there's something you know he
built a kind of visual
language and it is difficult
actually in some ways not to imagine
what
seuss you know encountering that poem
what the visual language would say about
it and so you know it wasn't like
everything had an image but um but yes a
good many of them
did so anyway yeah i would love to see
it i would love to see it
okay the second uh question from last
week is
again a comment uh which i think you
pulled up a visual
for this one it is this meaning this
podcast is like if shaggy and velma got
phds and started a podcast zach do you
want to put up shaggy and velma
all right here they are right yeah um
now i just think i just think this is
that guy needs a haircut more than you
do he yeah right
no i think this comment is is is just a
little unfair because
i you know i actually i just i don't
know
i i i'm sure i watched scooby-doo a
couple times but
i was i don't know the characters well
enough i
i don't have a deep knowledge let's put
it this way i mean
uh i think velma is more on target for
you
she's uh you know adventurous
a little bookish you know it's it's it's
not way off but i just think you know
um you know 10 times lovelier than velma
as lovely as she is
and you know and you find uh
uh what's his name shaggy a bit of a
shmo
you know i just i i just you know
i don't know i i i wasn't sure what to
make of it okay
and yet and yet here it is and yet i
read it to you laughing last week and
you said
what and then you found this image and
you said you didn't read it i said i
think you wanted me to all right so here
we go yeah okay anyway
i i just thought i'd mention it because
actually i do think there is something
very incisive about
the idea of them having gotten phds and
started a podcast and
it was it was pretty fun wanted to
highlight it
next question i recently got my masters
from an oxbridge college
just after racial bias training became
mandatory for current and future
students
is a phd worth the personal cost of
speaking
untruths well
yeah you know this is a tough one i i
have been saying
to our children that in many ways
i don't think i
could do what they must now do living in
a world in which
untruths are so
regularly deployed and with such
such force behind them so i don't know
what to make of this because
obviously there is a logic about living
to fight another day
this is something it took me a long time
to
understand but you know there's only so
far you can go with that and then the
other thing is
if you decide well live to fight another
day has to be the key rubric because if
you're going to accomplish something
you have to accomplish that first that's
like the second half of is this the hill
you want to die on
right i mean even if those don't emerge
from the same thing it's it's definitely
you can definitely put those two ideas
together and make them saying yeah they
they um they are closely
related and the problem is this isn't
the hill you want to die on then you're
going to live to fight another day
right if the person asking you if that's
the hill you want to die on is also
holding a weapon
it's a very different thing and so yes
the
the problem i would say is
you know none of us gets out alive there
probably is a hill you should therefore
be willing to die
on right there are important things in
the world and you the preservation of
your
well-being is not um ultimately
viable especially if you are part of a
society that is
committing obvious suicide right
so the hill to die on is somewhere and
uh we all ought to find that hill
um i don't know what to do you know i
have almost no doubt that i would not
i mean i barely survived the phd program
we went through at the time and this was
not a component of the problem
so yep wasn't there no it wasn't there
there were lots of other problems and
my you know instinct to go after things
that aren't right definitely got me in a
lot of trouble but it was scientific
trouble
um and you know kind i'm proud of i
think the fights i
chose were were good ones and i would
still think that even if i
hadn't uh hadn't finished but but
nonetheless i don't know what advice to
give people going now because on the one
hand
the institutional structure is so broken
that it's not
obvious to me that having the degree and
therefore
the authority or having the training and
therefore
the knowledge is all that valuable in
and of itself because the programs
are um delusional in the first place for
the most part so
well i mean
that will obviously vary to some degree
by discipline
and the problem more widely is you know
if this person says
mandatory for current future students
it's not clear if in this question
racial bias training is mandatory in
this field
you know for for that department yep or
if it's college-wide
yes increasingly these things are
becoming college-wide and we saw
evidence
you know we saw yet more evidence this
week from a couple of terrific pieces
one written by barry weiss one written
by
caitlyn flanagan on what is happening to
secondary ed
especially the elite private schools and
you know it's whole institutions that
are falling to this thing
um but presumably the world does still
need
um chemists and you know like so
i fear that art which we need will fall
completely as a set of disciplines
sooner than this than the stem
fields will uh because airplanes will
start falling out of the sky and bridges
will start collapsing
well but i mean in some sense this is my
point is
we do absolutely need these things not
optional
and you cannot do it in a world where
your relationship to the truth
is held to be facultative as a matter of
your survival
therefore we are facing an existential
crisis and that does not mean that it is
clear that if you go into the field
that ultimately things sort out the
question is
is it necessary if your point is
actually chemistry is very very
important and we have to
remain clear-headed about it then the
point is maybe that has to be fought
outside that if you go if you go into
the thing that it owns and therefore can
force you
to accept fiction that it wokeness not
it chemistry
correct chemistry having surrendered to
wokeness and i
can speak less about what's going on in
chemistry biology yeah but biology
clearly has right otherwise there would
be an uproar amongst biologists saying
actually that's that nonsense that
you're peddling over at scientific
american about
us having gotten past the sexual binary
is nonsense and
you know no and you get people who can
legitimately say
how can you claim that sex is binary
when all of these
researchers and scientists and
pediatricians and such say the other
like well
i can't explain them but that doesn't
make them right yeah
so what you know this goes back to
the idea of zero being a special number
right to the extent that there are not
programs that we can point you to where
the chemistry is free
of wokeness that tells you what battle
we're involved in we're battle in a
battle in which
there can be no program in which
chemistry is not afflicted by wokeness
because if there was it would obviously
be the top program
and therefore if if the outsiders can
race to the front of the race just
simply by not being crazy
then the point is that cannot be allowed
which is actually that's why we go after
merit right which is quite viewable in
the attack on substack
this week so there are now calls to i
don't know this
substack sensor it's journalists
and the point is well we can't very well
have a game in which all of the
mainstream outlets have to say these
crazy wrong
things if they're a bunch of people who
are liberated to go to the audience
directly and say true things because of
course
they will be the only game in town so
how can they not be the only game in
town
we're going to have to de-platform so i
didn't i didn't know that it happened um
i met with the two founders of sub stack
a few years ago back before
really almost anyone had heard of them
and they were they came they flew up
here to
to talk to me about whether or not i
wanted to start one and i was thinking
about and i ended up not and i
and i still don't have one as as you
know um
but i specifically asked them i think
this was right after
the kerfuffle with patreon over sargon
of akkad and i was thinking okay maybe
not patreon maybe sub stack
i tend to want to put out more written
content anyway than video content
um and i was really impressed with with
these two guys but i asked them
specifically what
you know what will your policy be in
censorship space and um
they didn't hedge a lot but they had
just a tiny bit and you know i felt it
was
it was not that that is the reason that
i didn't end up creating a sub stack i
didn't want
at that point we i think we had maybe
just gotten our book contract i didn't
want to feel confined to be writing
something on a regular basis for that
for a different audience
but i remember the three of us having a
conversation that i think was
was good on all fronts in which i said
you will
you will want to be very clear up front
with this because it will come for you
yes it will come for you the question is
what do you say because of course you
don't want to set up a policy that
allows people to put
truly dangerous possibly illegal
whatever it is so you need to set up a
rule
that explains how discretion will be
willed and what will be protected
but that you know i don't envy anybody
who has to write that policy and then
uh face the consequences it's not a
simple matter
i agree so all right yeah
do mammals regularly physically
discipline children
if so does it suggest evolutionary
utility or cast
doubt on quote negative reinforcement
never works
do mammals physically discipline
presumably their
own children non-human mammals
physically discipline their own children
as presumably the question yeah the only
example that comes to mind
is um male lions cuffing cubs who are
playing on them when they're just sort
of fed up
like leave me alone kid um
and but that's not that's not a
there's nothing abstract about that it's
not a i saw you doing something that
requires discipline it's like you're
sitting on my head and i wish you
wouldn't i'm going to
get you out of here yeah i think it's a
very good question
um i agree with you i struggle for any
example
other than that one and other analogs
you know probably you'd find the same in
hyenas but it's not a different reese's
macaques probably
yeah um but
i think part of the answer is that
there's a reason for it and it actually
goes to what
i have frequently said about school
about school as a supplement
right and that the fact of school being
a supplement is the result of the fact
that we live
in novel circumstances where supplements
are necessary right
hunter-gatherers are not uneducated what
they are
is educated by the intersection between
watching their immediate ancestors their
living ancestors
do the job that they do in the world and
you know following suit so the point is
the world trains you properly
you don't need to be scolded so imagine
imagine the following example
imagine that you are
walking down a sidewalk as a child
and you are not paying attention to your
trajectory being straight
right there is a very abrupt place at
which the world becomes
fatally dangerous and the possibility of
straying over that line
absent-mindedly does not mirror
many things in nature now there are
cliff edges but you are
actually well programmed to appreciate
the hazard of them rather than
you know a six-inch drop that could get
you killed i do think these are two
different things though
and we address both of them in our book
so this idea of
uh discrete hard borders that um you
know cliff edges
and to some degree water edge uh being
the closest analog but things like the
garbage disposal
the curb the swimming pool right
where in all of those cases there's
nothing that begins to give you a sense
of the encroaching danger
and cliff edges maybe a little bit but
even most
natural bodies of water give you some
indication like it's getting
you're sinking into the earth more as
you get close something like that right
but then this question of um you know
what do you need to be schooled in
uh is i i guess it's there's an
overlapping
thing there but it's but it's distinct
in that mo there's
not only is there i mean this is
specifically about punishment
and maybe schooled and scolded maybe
they have actually etymology
in common but um not only
is school almost unknown in non-human
animals
but schooling in school is almost
unknown in humans
aside from modern environments that are
informed by weird
western educated industrialized rich
democratic countries
and in fact there are lots of examples
of people who are doing
um really detailed high skill things
where the stories that they tell are of
course i wasn't schooled in this
you know here's an example god there's
one one thing we cite
in there i can't remember i think it's
um one of these maybe it's these
japanese women
abalone divers i may be conflating two
stories here in which
uh the anthropologist is saying so you
know you learned from your mom she's
like no i didn't learn from my mom my
mom cuffed me and told me to go away and
said i had to learn this on my own there
was no way i learned from her
and so there's an actual like antipathy
towards schooling and towards
instruction in
not just um most species but um
where it could possibly be being
happening but um also in
many human cultures um well i agree but
to draw the connection about
why why i see the parallel in here
is that to the extent
so when i scold one of our children
i am effectively if i'm doing it right
i am speaking for their future self i am
i am chastising them so that they will
learn a lesson that their future
self will be glad that they have learned
and my point about
animals mammals other than people
is that in some sense the
willingness so i am also borrowing from
my authority as a parent
but the alignment between the
parents view of the world if you imagine
a jaguar
at the edge of a cliff with a with a cub
the cub has every interest in just
simply modeling the state of mind of the
adult and taking it on
and so as that parent becomes wary
because the cliff is a hazard
my guess is there's a almost seamless
transmission
of this is my opinion of this and this
should be your opinion of this rather
than
the attempt to uh um escape authority
which is more complex in in humans but
so something like that i do think that
there is there's an analogy yeah that's
good
um one more question from last week are
there any health benefits to kombucha
or is it just a trend i like it but how
effective are the probiotics in
preventing
illnesses um
i don't know the research but i
have the sense that
it like other ferments are useful
um to varying degrees depending on the
brand and the age and
all of this and your particular health
at
helping you maintain and maybe helping
you establish
a healthy gut microbiome and i will say
that i my very first kombucha was at the
invitation of joe rogan
in his studio when he was still in
california the one time that we did joe
rogan together
as we were leaving he said hey do you
want a kombucha for the road
for the road kombucha i think i'll have
one of joe rogan's
very nice very cold kombuchas and i did
and i'm a fan ever since
yeah no i i have actually i the one i
got from
joe's fridge i've been drinking it very
i've been savoring it and that one has
ever less value
or ever more value depending i mean it's
a it's a living drink so
um sorry uh
but uh yeah so i don't know about
kombucha in particular
yeah i do have the anecdotal sense um
so long time viewers will know that i
had an issue with asthma which largely
almost completely like 90
went away with my elimination of wheat
from my diet
um to the extent that there's any
residual i actually find certain things
are very effective one hydration number
one
and second is fermented foods
such as kimchi and sauerkraut
and kombucha yes although i have i can
say that i have detected the difference
with sauerkraut and kimchi
i have not actually tested the
difference with kombucha but
my guess is it works similarly yeah
okay discord question for this week are
we meant to stay
are we meant to stay awake my computer
is not meant to stay awake apparently
not
are we meant to stay awake for a long
period of time than sleep for several
hours
or is this an unnatural way of doing
things that was incentivized to fit the
nine to five work schedule
how did our ancestors used to sleep what
is healthy and how do we know
that's a lot of questions yep um did you
have it you want to start
well sure i don't know where you'll be
headed with this i would say i think the
evidence is good that during
sleeping hours during our hours in which
it's too dark to be productive out in
the world
the evidence is not one long bout of
sleep but there's a pattern
a natural pattern that involves waking
up periodically
i will say that for my part anecdotally
i have the following experience if i
wake up during the night
and make contact with the clock so that
i know what time it is
this is an unnatural circumstance clocks
are unnatural
no but you can look at the sky and see
that where the moon is
yeah maybe if there isn't cloud cover et
cetera
i think there would be a lot of yeah my
sleep becomes super regular out in
nature if i go backpack
i was just saying like what are there
ways that you could tell what time it is
relative to when you thought you would
be sleeping out in nature
often yes not not as precisely as a
clock not as precise and not reliably so
the moon uh could be obscured by clouds
or whatever but
so when you do that when i do this if i
make eye contact with the clock let's
say it's 2 30
and i make eye contact with the clock
and i say ah it's 2 30.
i will very frequently be able to wake
up with
shocking precision at just about the
moment that i had
hoped to get up and when that happens
one of the things we don't
take seriously enough is the hazard of
arbitrarily
awakening in the middle of a sleep cycle
yeah that ain't good for you i guarantee
but um but the degree to which
one does not feel some awful burden of
having to get out of bed if you wake up
naturally
at the end of a sleep cycle rather than
arbitrarily in the middle of one
is uh rather surprising yes
and so anyway it is very good for me to
have a moment of consciousness in the
middle of the night that allows me to
calibrate where i am
and then my assumption is that my
regular clock-like
functions in the mind actually count
down or something and
result in me landing at the right moment
i wonder though
why why should it be more precise if you
wake up in the middle of the night as
opposed to
counting down from if you know what time
it is when you go to bed
that's a great question my and this is
testable i think
one possibility is that there are
processes taking place at different
rates and that partly our desire to be
asleep
all night without a break results in a
miscalibrated something because there's
a natural
break in the middle but if you go if if
the last period before you wake up
is continuous and it's had a calibration
it's much more likely
and i've wondered this too you know the
different types of sleep tend to have
um known periodicities but they have
variants and what i've never run into
and this may well be out in the
literature and presumably some sleep
where
researchers researchers know this but i
just don't know what the answer is
is is that variance in periodicity are
population-wide variants or also an
individual variance which is to say
like if during rem sleep your
rem periods for instance tend to be 60
minutes long
is that always the case or if you wake
up at 2 30 in the morning and you know
you wanna get up at seven
um can your brain go like okay i'm gonna
give i'm not gonna be able to do the
math because i pick difficult numbers
uh but you know can can your brain say
actually that's five and a half hours
and so i'm gonna i'm gonna make those 65
minute
um you know rem periods rather than
60 and so get you up at you know five
minutes to seven because i did do the
math
but i'm not like i'm not even sure if
that's right if it's all around in the
second half then i don't remember
exactly where all this thing gets
gets divvied up um
like you could when i'm where you get
where you go i sure do
in fact um i i find very funny the idea
of
um you know if you got a lot of pressure
sleep quickly you know yeah and i don't
mean for a brief period of time i mean
you try to pack it up or pack it in yeah
that's right yeah
and um yeah i mean there's a there's a
ton to say
here about sleep um
i don't know what evidence there is but
i suspect it is
it would be true if there were evidence
and it is
would be true and if there's not
evidence yet um that
many people absent electric lights and
um
other indicators of urbanization
do tend to sleep in chunks that aren't
one
one big chunk in the middle of the night
or
throughout the night but i don't i don't
know what the research is beyond like
like narrative evidence from medieval
european peasants or something you know
it's like that's the thing i have in my
head is
you know waking up and spending an hour
talking or something and then going back
to bed
maybe also into it and maybe there's a
hunter guy i feel like i know like
bits and pieces where like yes people do
this but they're
it's they're all like little examples
that strike me as anecdote at the level
that i can
come up with them yep okay
um first question from this last hour
what is more likely evergreen naming a
building after the two of you
or 12 impartial jurors being empaneled
unafraid of the consequences of a
chauvin acquittal
what real peace can be brought from the
public sacrifice of even a despised man
see john adams and the boston massacre
yeah i think it's more likely that
evergreen names are building after us
frankly
yeah i mean it is and you know i tried
to point this out
early on because he did that and it's
you know not only
is it very unlikely that jurors could
possibly
set aside the hazard uh i mean even
you know well-intentioned objective
jurors cannot be
deaf to the fact that the consequences
of
exonerating chauvin could
set the world on fire and so anyway yeah
people are human
and this is this is incredibly dangerous
but
just to be clear you were just you were
trying to say
i i believe take out their own personal
safety
um if they are even if they are
completely
anonymous and protected and there's no
way to ever know who any of them are
the effects on the world will be
something that they would
have to live in and you're feeling
responsible for and in fact i think you
can
you can detect this very thing in
what i think is the only famous thing
that rodney king has ever said
rodney king said can't we all just get
along and you know my recollection of
that i hope it's accurate
my recollection is that he was
uh shocked and feeling responsible
for essentially you know rioting
taking place uh on on his behalf
right in his name even though he never
wanted his name right and so
anyway i mean i do think his point was
the right one i i
respect him greatly for for what he for
trying to step in and restore
sanity but the basic point is yes any
rational person
has to cannot put aside
entirely the fact that terrible things
could happen as the result
of a verdict in this case and the
problem is
that a the facts of the case
are complex to say the least
right and i said this on rogan and
didn't know what would happen but the
facts of the case are complex
which means and you engaged john mcorder
in a conversation about this as part of
your conversation with him
last summer as well yep that's true um
but the necessity
right what i fear most in some ways
is the sense
that the system will declare that he
must be convicted
and that it will convict him unfairly
because
some way in some ways the system will
just register the greater good
of not setting riots off and all of this
as paramount and the point is you cannot
have a system
in which we suspend due process because
if we don't suspend due process people
will bring
violence to the public right you cannot
have a system
run by by those willing to engage in
violence that is
the beginning of the end and so we must
have a fair trial
irrespective of what happens downstream
of it right and i'm not convinced that
we will
no i i agree um just one more one more
point on this
you've seen these um these visuals like
the pyramid of white supremacy
right so it's like genocide is at the
top and things like
being race blind are at the bottom and
the idea is that everything above
something on the bottom level uh is as
built on everything that came before and
you know these are super divisive and
frankly racist ropes that are now
spreading but
um i saw one this week that actually had
why can't we all just get along
as part of the white supremacist pyramid
marvelous yeah well yeah starting next
week if ibram candy does not uh respond
we will begin
to build a framework in which
um being not racist is once again
on the map and understood to be so i
will hope i'm super not racist
that's true but this week what is it you
know we're just in trouble saying such
things um
where were we here we go greetings
professors would you give any advice for
an involuntary
university student who withdrew in his
late 20s who is still haunted by hunger
for knowledge
and the guilt for not meeting his
ambition of making an intellectual
contribution
so i would one thing i would say is i
don't yeah the
the idea that you have guilt for not
meeting your ambition of making an
intellectual contribution
um based on the fact that you didn't
finish
college um there's a there's a
disconnect there
there i wish there were more
opportunities to make
intellectual contributions that um were
easy and that there were
a route for some people that was clear
and that you know there is no clear
route at this point
uh because the one that we had is so
broken but um there are plenty of ways
to make intellectual contributions that
don't actually require
a degree so i don't think you should
feel guilt
for withdrawing from especially a broken
system
and imagine that that means that you are
thus thwarted
yeah i agree with that and i would
maybe um say more directly that you know
speaking as professors speaking as
people who
did you know in your case you shine
throughout the system in my case i made
it through
to you know to phd top level you can
make degree wise but when i and earned
you know
not just did you ultimately get the
degree
um but also earned uh one of the
top awards um for the work that you did
as you know as did i a different one but
yeah um but it you know you didn't just
by some measures you squeaked by because
there were people who didn't want you to
succeed
um but there were others who saw what
you were doing to be clear
i have no sense of embarrassment about
what i
accomplished i think i accomplished
quite a bit more than was necessary to
get
a degree but um i did barely get by
because
i did have a lot of antagonists by the
time it was over but anyway the point of
this
some of whom you poked first i i may
have kicked the hornet's nest but
the point i wanted to make is even
having gotten the degrees
and seen the system and then taught in
the system
for 14 years i never
never assume that if somebody did not
graduate from
any level of this that that tells me
where they are with respect
to their ability to think i never do and
the reason i don't is that i've seen
so many counter examples of people who
are
wickedly good at thinking who don't have
the
credentials and so but you and i are
unusual in this
most people in the system take the
degree
as the thing that you need if i'm going
to talk to you
like without the degree i know you're
not worthy is i mean sometimes actually
the stated position
of some academics well actually okay
there are two things that need to be
said here
one if you did it without
the system if you've managed to figure
out how to think without all of that
scaffolding
in my book you get more credit right to
the extent that you
are self-taught all the better but i
also want to
just say i go got my degree in the end
because i had to in order to get the job
that i was already doing i was told that
i would need the degree
if they were to hire me permanently and
there was a competition and all of that
but whatever
the point is i went through this phase
and you know it wasn't that i couldn't
have gotten my degree because i couldn't
have gotten it
i was disgusted with the process by the
time that we moved to olympia
for you to start the job that you had
gotten and
so i didn't really want the degree i
didn't
like what it meant i didn't like what
came with it and so ultimately i was
forced to go back and get it i'm glad
that that happened
however i know that
one of the things that i valued about
not having it
was that it meant that all of the people
who don't take you seriously because you
don't have the degree
i didn't need to bother with them right
so it sorted the world nicely people who
were still willing to interact over
content even though i didn't have the
degree
that tended to be a smaller much more
interesting group of people so anyway
um you know there is something to be
said for having the degree it settles
certain things in people's minds but
um no if you if you're
maintaining an intellectual life outside
of that system more power to you
yeah so you know the question is you
know what what do you do you're still
haunted by hunger for knowledge
you've got guilt i think you know
hopefully we've assuaged the guilt
explain why the guilt doesn't have any
place here
haunted you know haunted by hunger for
knowledge
you don't say anything about what kinds
of things you're interested in so
um you know it would be impossible for
us to say how you go about doing this
but
you know become an autoduct become
someone who can figure out how
to how to learn themselves how to teach
themselves how to learn
and um and be you know
a critical part of that would be being
open just remaining open
uh to any any time you have a glimmer of
like oh that might be interesting
oh my brain just sparked over there um
you know
unless it's junk fill in the blank you
know junk food
junk sex junk news junk whatever it is
um
if you didn't think you were interested
in
i don't even know um you know 12th
century china and you see
something that goes like oh i wonder you
know go
go watch it go read it go do whatever it
is and
you know you won't be able to follow all
of those trails we are
big fans as we write about in in our
book
of um being generalist as much as
possible but recognize that
every every thing that you do that
expands your breath
has the likely cost of not being able to
go deep on something
another step deeper on something you
already know so you know
certainly breadth early because if you
start
investing in depth early at the point
that you do get exposed to more stuff
you're much more likely to find that
actually the thing you went deep on
should have been like fifth on your list
of things you wanted to go deep on and
there's other things more interesting to
you out there
so expose yourself as broadly as
possible early on
to figure out what kind of knowledge
you're really most interested in well
like what
what ways of informing yourself and
producing new information in the world
are you
are you both best at and most driven to
participate in
and i would just add you know as much as
a lot of the modern landscape is
heavily compromised by all sorts of
stuff there's also really really good
stuff there and the number of people who
will teach you what they know
for free on youtube is staggering and
the number of ways
i'm very fond of videos in which
somebody who knows how to do something
amazing
shows the production of it without a
word and the point is that's a great way
to train your mind how much do i
understand about what they just did in
order to reach this endpoint
all right that's a great exercise and
especially if you have the ability to
try to
recreate it well that's it it's
really low yep we got a helicopter
flying real low over our house
it's gonna crash into one of our very
many trees that was an airplane not a
helicopter oh yeah it didn't have the
yeah yeah okay then it's not gonna land
so i'm not i'm not
i'm not so concerned yeah um
first of all thank you for the podcast
secondly where can one start learning
biology outside of the academic system
well so this this is a related question
right and you know partially
partially here to some degree although
we're not
we're not trying to create curriculum so
it's not organized and
um you know similarly our book which
still isn't out for
six more months um actually six months
tomorrow i think
um is
you know organizes to some degree but
isn't meant as a curriculum
and so um you know depending on what
kind of biology
you're interested in for instance
the one book that you and i almost
always started with
when in each of our programs was the
selfish gene
1976 richard dawkins still the classic
in need of updating brett um
and and yet you know there's a
few ways in which it's dated but he like
he wrote such
a terrific book that although it could
use some updates
there's very little in it that is out of
date if that distinction makes it it was
it was almost entirely right as far as
it went
right there is but it but it remains
almost entirely right as far as it goes
yes which is surprising
both of those things and to the right
degree to which uh
the field has moved on and discovered
great
evolutionary truths to stack on top of
it is uh it's
it's incorrect it has not largely
happened so um
in any case yeah it's a great place to
start and i mean and frankly if
you know if you're interested in sort of
the other
half of evolutionary biology um which is
to say
the sort of origin of species and deep
history stuff another dawkins book which
was always a book that i used when i
taught vertebrate evolution
is an ancestor's tale which is terrific
that's a great one
i would recommend if you're interested
in adaptation itself
climbing mount improbable is quite
excellent more dawkins
more dawkins well yeah i mean the man is
a gifted writer and
deeply insightful if you're interested
in uh
tropical biology uh
short book uh but you and you've
mentioned it and i feel like it was
right here there's climbing man
improbable there's a selfish gene
tropical nature um tropical nature yeah
uh just absolutely terrific that's great
um you know we're
we're going to have no answers off the
top of our head if what you're really
interested in getting into is molecular
biology for instance yeah but you know a
lot of that stuff too is available on
youtube if you're interested in how
cells function you got to figure out
where the good stuff
is rather than the stuff that cuts
corners but
there's a lot you can learn cellular
biology on youtube
um that sort of thing cool
43 minutes yep well
we're gonna we we've only answered a
couple here in this
hour so we're gonna get through a few
more of these at least
uh wouldn't
i think so these are two questions from
the same person i think they're
different questions but they may both
have to do with
your conversation with jordan peterson
i'm not totally sure okay wouldn't
consciousness overriding the genes as
you put it simply be in service of the
genes as well
since evolution would select for
self-policing genes to increase fitness
by weeding out the bad and keeping
the good lovely question
so that's actually did you talk so again
i haven't listened to your conversation
did you talk about omega with
jordan yep so i let me just read the
second question because i
the short answer to that question is yes
right um
in service of the genes wouldn't it be
in service of the genes
yes but you have to be really careful
about what yes
it is there's no question the fact that
we are going to drive ourselves extinct
by following the genes narrowly and
continuing to play the game that they
taught us to play
so well right does not mean
that it is useful that ultimately the
preservation of those genes would be in
the genes interest if only the genes
could figure it out
yeah but that's not i think you read a
lot more into the question than is there
wouldn't consciousness overriding the
genes as you put it simply be in service
of the genes as well
that's i mean that's part of the omega
principle right there yes but the
problem
is the game theory of course and so the
point is
um the recogni the recognition that this
is ultimately true that if only the
genes could think
they would be in favor of the things
that we think on their behalf is true
but it does not solve the game theory
problem which is deep and for which i've
already been taken to task
once by somebody who did not realize
that i was aware of that hazard
um by a biologist yeah you'll tell me
off here
of course um i love jordan peterson
uh the second question reads but feel
that he misses the mark with regards to
games
of social hierarchies by not realizing
the competence itself
is a form of power one might wield i
enjoyed seeing how much you agreed on in
the end
so i'm not sure that's a question but um
you might riff briefly
well i agree jordan and i do agree on a
ton
and i love that and i think he and i
have a kind of shared
delight over the fact that these come
from very very different places and so
you know if there's one way to know when
you're thinking correctly
it's that somebody who has high quality
tools starting from a completely
different place
arrives in the same location or roughly
there
so i feel like again you know i will
i will watch or listen to your
conversation with him and i look forward
to doing so but
um not having seen really anything from
him for a while
um now one of the things that i think
the two of you have in common
and it's not the only thing is that you
both
love it when people disagree with you
and um
you know a lot of people can't imagine
that there's anyone like that out there
um i try for that to be true for me
but i have to i have to try and
there's definitely been moments
especially in teaching when it felt
amazing but it's
but i think i i know that you and i
think that jordan
actually just just walk around the world
like
hoping for people to disagree with you
at some level
um not you know not out of a sense of
you know
n not wits and not people in bad faith
in all of this but
you want to be challenged so that what
you know to be true becomes a better and
better representation of the truth
yeah and in fact um one of the things
that i'm of reality
most uh frustrated by
i guess i would even say angry about
with the
collapse of the institutions and taking
out
our field with it is that
you know it did not
create the proper
um what's the word proper level of
challenge
right it's really easy to beat the field
because the field is pretty stupid
right the field is stupid not because
the people are in it are stupid but
because
it had there there are reward structures
that cause the field to stick with wrong
ideas long after it should
which makes it easier easy to out think
it um
but that's not nearly that's not so fun
what would be really fun is if the field
were super vibrant
and the point is yes it would then be
harder to beat but the point is the
quality of all of our thinking would go
up
because there would be you know high
quality challenge
and so anyway i think i'm sure that
jordan has a similar
sense i and you know and in essence we
end up having to meet people from other
fields
you know renegades from different fields
may actually be better at pushing each
other around
than members of your own field whose um
errors in thought you already know
thoroughly yeah and you all you share
a sort of intellectual development and
developmental environment
so that you know your biases and
assumptions are the same and it's harder
to see
where they're flawed yep
do you fix your own dogs every article
online
seems that this is about reproductive
fixing yeah i gleaned that fix
i hate that i'm going to use the
scarecrow do you fix no it says then
we're going to fix it we're going to fix
them right up yeah
do you fix your own dogs every article
online seems only to be propaganda to
exaggerate the benefits
i can't shake the feeling that i chose
wrong and if i'm a responsible owner
fixing it could be a negative for the
dog
it's a real question yep and it has
potentially different
um different answers depending on the
sex the dog um
yeah we've we've fixed all of our
animals um yeah we
can we've only had one dog we've had a
lot of cats
and we fixed all of them we thought
about not doing it
yep but it's just impractical which
doesn't mean you know if
if you've got the you know if you're
living on a ranch and your dog is able
to be outside and all of this
that's one thing but um it just isn't it
is not practical for most of us and you
know
for us it's i don't you know i don't
think
the argument that it is you know
worse for the animal is all that
persuasive because i think
these animals have a very good deal if
they have an owner that really cares
about them
and you know and will go the distance
for them it's
less like you know especially for males
i think
it's less like the experience of being a
wild animal yeah it's
less like the life they would have had
yeah but they still have a terrific
life yeah they have a terrific life um
but you know in ex
the trade is a good one and i think
you know what i was going to say is that
for you and me
obviously we're animal behaviorists to
the extent that these animals
bring a degree of animal behavior to our
house that then we can think about and
talk about that's great and so we would
like to leave them as intact as possible
but even we
with that as a as a priority
it's it's real you know i mean we're
facing the discipline issues on the
two kittens and that this is a problem
more with cats than dogs where
uh early bad developmental experiences
that we weren't present for
that we weren't present for had nothing
to you know no knowledge of
uh have implications for the way the
animal is
you know these are well socialized
creatures but they're
not easy to get along with they're
destructive and very hard to
to change their behavior among other
things
but you know and styrofoam i think
especially fairfax would be
even more of a terror if he was intact
and so
anyway i think i think the way i would
think of it is
um but for the ability to render them
capable of playing along in an internal
and or indoor environment without
creating havoc they wouldn't have lives
at all
yep and so uh you know that's the trade
and
yeah we just kind of got to get used to
it yep i agree
um last week's potatoes don't do or
don't want to be eaten talk
which is to say the discord question
from last week about um
really should we be eating potatoes made
me think
is domestication a good evolutionary
strategy for the domesticated for the
gene the individual or the species and
what does this mean
if the aliens invade
so we talked about the domestication
question last week a fair bit and yeah
the answer
you know ends up being just as we were
just saying with regard to cats and dogs
you know they have
they are alive uh and probably wouldn't
be but for us having domesticated them
or you know fixed those individuals i
would say there's one
major difference in the agricultural
version of that story versus the pet
version which is that because the
agricultural version takes place
out of sight and is so directly driven
by marketed incentives
the way we raise animals in that context
is
absolutely appalling and there's no
defending it yes
that is separate from the question of in
principle
at the point that you domesticate an
animal and then
at the end of its life you eat it
what does it think of that and obviously
we're not talking consciously but
would it prefer not to be and not to get
eaten or does it prefer to be
and have a good life that suddenly comes
to an end
i think it's quite clear that our
instinct because we
if we try to put ourselves in the mind
of the domesticated animal we are so
horrified by this
we cannot grapple we cannot grasp
the actual long and short of it um
which is you know look you know you're
gonna die
it could be horrible does that mean
you'd rather not have been
no right right we all get that and so
you know what does this mean if the
aliens invade well
um if if they're those kinds of aliens
who are interested in domesticating us
or in driving us extinct um
you know the the option that's not on
the table there
uh that uh
that we took off the table for um
say chickens a long time ago um but
there would only be a few
uh wild whatever they are junglefowl
around today but for that um is
the equivalent is where we are now so in
if it's those aliens we prefer that they
never show up right
so if they've shown up do we prefer to
be domesticated versus to be driven
extinct
i think you know the logic has to extend
to evolutionarily we prefer to be
domesticated but you know the third
option is we prefer they're not there
we prefer that they don't show up and
force the choice on us well
i think it's a little different for one
thing i think there is
zero chance that um the aliens
would we're talking about aliens that
are capable of getting here which tells
us a certain amount about
who and what they are they're not going
to come here to eat us
right well so i did preface this by
saying if it's if it's you know those
kinds of aliens they've come here
they're hostile they want one of two
things they either want the planet for
themselves or they're willing to keep us
around as domesticated
but that's that's the question is what
is the viable category in which they
take us on
as uh co-inhabitants of the planet you
know if the planet has resources
you know minerals that they need and
they're gonna exterminate us then
we know what our approach is if they are
going to leave us intact here
maybe they think we're cute well but
that's the thing is
i mean like really like pets the well
you know and actually this is this is
well done
in the tripod series in which
um effectively this has happened and
um there is a chapter in there the
master's cat
i think in which one of the people who's
been taken into the tripod city
understands himself to be effectively
the
cat of his master and it's not a very
nice
it's not the relationship that we all
have with our cats it's
it's much more terrible but in any case
the point is
if the aliens came here and were
interested
in a mutualism right which is what we
are effectively arguing we have with our
domesticated animals then the point is
actually there are mutualisms that would
be worth signing up for
but we would not want to sign up for a
subservient relationship
in which our interests don't count and
their interests count and
we take on that role but you know let's
put it this way
there are some things that the aliens
probably know that it would be a really
good time if we figured it
to it'd be real good moment to figure
that out because we may not be around
much longer if we don't
yeah so you're inviting them uh
i i believe uh they should make contact
they can reach the moderator
at moderator dot dot course dot
moderator darkhorse dot
moderator yeah all right
um once
content generating neural net tech for
instance deep fakes
makes video footage inadmissible might
neocon
blackmail paddle cults like epstein's
cease
media was never proof like drawing
writing and gossip until
1800's film tech
that is a that is a i'm not getting i'm
not getting the assertion yet what
so i get the deep fakes once basically
deep fakes are so good you can't tell
that that's what they are
um i you know neocon blackmail paddle
cults
um like epstein's
cease so the the the claim is
that epstein did whatever he whatever
that
thing was by uh effectively holding
holding people hostage because he had
evidence against them
i think um
yeah that that that's where we are um
i'm not sure that we are headed to the
priors of this question
in other words are we
not going to be in an arms race about
deep fakes in other words i'm not
convinced that there is a simple end
point to
the admissibility of video evidence what
i think you will have
is increasing sophistication at avoiding
detection
you will you know so we expect an arms
race where there is increasing
sophistication of detection
yeah as well and i i've seen almost none
of that
and as gosh um
right after obama left office i saw
a pretty compelling deep fake of him
saying things he'd never said so that's
now
you know four years ago yeah um and
presumably a lot has happened since then
in terms of the technology but what i
haven't seen
is the evidence of where the the counter
part of that arms race is
yeah uh you don't want to know it'll
it'll it'll drive you no no
the this would be the the important part
the good part you're not going to like
it
it's not good enough no it's horrifying
in its own right like imagine that you
have to
bug yourself in order to ensure that if
somebody comes up with a deep fake of
you you can prove it didn't happen
right um i'm moving to the amazon
no no it's already there where where
okay um let me get
there's too many good questions here um
another
two more and then we'll skip to we'll go
to the next hour gosh i'm sorry
um does encouraging humans to be more
cooperative and less competitive from a
young age
there's an extra word in here hold on um
could encouraging humans to be more
cooperative and less competitive from a
young age be the solution
to counteract our gene propagation
mechanism as a species
if not then what will be a viable
solution to this problem
the problem is we cooperate
to compete and so to the extent that you
are teaching collaboration you are also
teaching competition and there's a
question about what level to teach it
right who will you collaborate with
against whom
and so yes there are likely to be
developmental answers if we could figure
out how to teach the lessons about
how to collaborate we could get rid of
processes that are
dangerous and destructive um but
naming the here's the thing that you
know i mean look sports teach you to
cooperate to compete right that's the
perfect example
yep right so sports are good they'll
teach you certain stuff they probably
teach you how to fight a war
right if you're going to be you know in
a group of people that has to face
danger
together knowing how they're going to
think it's it's very analogous to what
happens on a
a sports pitch but um
what the lesson is for the game
theoretic problem that the question
the questioner is asking about i don't
think we know and we should be
we should be figuring it out as i think
the answer but i don't think we know yet
yeah okay um there's actually just a
comment here and then one more question
that we'll move to
the next hour the comment is
the problem apropos our conversation
last hour
the problem is that the simple
diagnostic they use for depression also
covers normal sadness
and we live in a time of
irresponsibility people would rather
take meds
than make better or new life choices and
i think this is you know
due to the point that you made that
depression
um is is a category that includes more
than one thing
it's both the pathological form and the
non-pathological form right
yeah the pathological form and the
non-pathological form exist together and
we tend to name the category
after the pathological form which gets
the study and that results in us not
rocking the uh benign version or the
useful version
right um brett regarding dyslexia
i know that heather is your reader and
ours but i see you read successfully at
times
what have you done to improve my son is
dyslexic
also what is the name of the third cat
it depends which is the third cat i
think probably so we've got fairfax and
moxie which is a uh
nickname of of melrose because
we try to name our cats after la streets
because when we don't we end up with
really stupid names and we'll tell you
that story
another time we won't we're not even
going to allude to i don't want them to
know that it happened
and yet our third cat the 10 year old
this month does not have a stupid name
and yet is also not named after an la
street and he
is tesla yeah named after the scientist
not the car
as you have said yes so uh what have you
done to improve
your reading well first of all i should
tell you when i was a kid
i lived in abject terror
of being asked to read out loud
and when as so frequently happened
there we were in a circle in the class
and we were each reading a paragraph
and it was coming around to me i would
abandon
all attempts to keep track of what we
were reading and i would count
paragraphs and try to figure out what
paragraph i was going to have to read
and i would try to read it through
enough times that i knew what it said so
at the point that i
had to read it out loud i did not
embarrass myself
um that sounds like an education no it
wasn't
it was it was a survival skill
it was terrible and i've seen even when
we were teaching undergraduate someone
we would
not you and i co-teach but when i taught
with some other faculty who
some of whom i really admired i would
see them
[Music]
do read aloud which didn't happen a lot
in college classrooms but did in some
and um and not let people pass
and my sense was you like you always let
someone pass
if they feel like there's no good that
will come of this
you don't force public reading on people
well here's the problem though i agree
because there's this particular thing
with reading
and what happened to me was traumatic it
was not useful
but i do have the sense on a related
topic
that is to say speaking that there is a
rubric like the following one
speaking publicly is a useful skill
like being able to read almost all of us
have
terror about it at first and the thing
that cures it
is getting through the terror
successfully a
small number of times so that you can
get to the point where there's actually
a reward for having done it
and so my sense is i don't want to free
i don't want to free students from
having to present
in front of the class and in fact i want
them to do it enough times that they
walk away with that skill okay but
that's that's different so i do want
i do want you to answer this question
but um
being required to read privately
in order to do work that is being
assigned is a legitimate requirement
for in an educational setting just as
and i i required this in almost all of
my programs
if any time i had a long project the
students were doing they were going to
have to not just write a paper but also
give a public presentation an oral
presentation of that work
um and yes people are terrified of it um
but really i don't
i hardly ever had anyone come to me and
say please please please can i try to
can i do something else i really am
scared of public speaking because
frankly in my classes as i think in
yours students just knew
how that would sound like yes i get that
you're scared and i get that this feels
like a trauma but that's part of the
reason you need to do it that is
different
from being forced to read or frankly
speak
in any given classroom conversation and
you know i feel like
some of those same faculty would be like
everyone has to talk at least once in
any given seminar like god no because
like i had an easy time reading aloud
yeah um as a
as a young student but i never talked in
class and the prospect of doing so
would have would have had exactly the
same effect on me as be
the prospect of reading aloud would have
had on you i wouldn't have had an
ability to pay attention to anything
that happened in the class
until i had finally said what you know
click kick check that little box which
would have completely
made the educational value of the
experience plummet okay
so i think the thing that you and i
would converge on here
is that the right thing to do is to be
upfront about the fact that this will be
required
absolutely very clear about why you're
requiring it
right that i actually and promise not to
spring it on someone right like you're
not gonna show up in class one day
not just not just like no but not just
bring it on them like
at some point during this quarter that
you're gonna be required to do this and
hey today's your day but no like
right on on you know on march 30th
that's the day that you have been
scheduled to come in and do your ten
minute this or your twenty like whatever
it is like you'll know that it's coming
yep and you're not plenty of no no pop
talk quizzes
like it's not gonna happen right um well
i think it should be open to people who
want to and frankly one of the things
that's best about having people
come up to the board and try to explain
something is that they actually that's
opt-in
yeah that's what i just said i'm i'm
up for that because one thing that you
know the distinction that i've
pointed to repeatedly about the
difference between knowing
how something is done and knowing how to
do it it's very easy to sit in a class
and not have any idea how hard it is to
convey something clearly
and so then they hear you say something
and it's not quite clear
in the sense of like come on and then
it's like okay
you try i really want you to try this
because you're going to find out what
happens
and then you'll know a lot no and
actually so we're spending probably too
much time here but
um i actually began
to do little public speaking things
through the
quarter especially if i was doing like a
two-quarter program in addition to some
larger presentation at the end for some
longer project
and the value in in that in part was
as soon as a student has gotten up in
front of the class and seeing what it is
to be faced with those faces some of
whom are paying attention and some of
whom aren't
and you can tell you just know and even
if you've banished the devices from the
classroom as i tended to
like you know who's actually paying
attention who's got their phone to the
table whatever you
can see in people's eyes every one of
those students as soon as they've been
in front of the class
becomes more receptive when you when
it's the faculty in front of the class
going like okay guys come on you all
need coffee like
look alive here people begin to have
theory of mind about the position of
what it is to be in front of the class
yeah that's true how did you teach
yourself to read more effectively
um well so i do think
a lot of this dyslexia so i don't really
think dyslexia
is a thing i think it is a symptom of
several things
and one of the problems with it is that
to the extent
that reading is arduous and that is my
experience of it
and i'm now to the point where i read
short things
easily but a very long thing still feels
quite arduous and so it's like
there's some distance you're comfortable
running and then there's some distance
that would feel like
a real slog it's like that distinction
so
one thing is if reading is arduous you
will do
less of it and i am convinced that
virtually
all of my trouble with spelling which is
like hilariously spectacular
is the result of a arm's length
relationship with reading it's not
it's some symptom of the same thing it's
a downstream consequence of what happens
if you yeah you just haven't seen as
many words people
i think of them auditorily because
that's my relationship to
language so
the answer is how do you get over it
read more
that's a slog so it's a little bit like
saying play better tennis but that is
where the key is and how do i
read out loud better than i once did i
very frequently go over the thing
beforehand because if i didn't i would
stumble over it like crazy
and it would be just like i mean i now
wouldn't be embarrassed about it but
but how did you become motivated to read
more
i mean you grew up in a family of
educated people
where they're you know there were there
were books lining walls and such
um i don't think your family had as much
of an emphasis like there wasn't as much
sitting around reading
as there was in my family but um you
know both your parents have advanced
degrees etc so
um it wasn't that you didn't know that
there was value in it
as a child how did you come to because i
think especially for
i remember what it says um
it just says my son is dyslexic but you
know how how do you
excite interest you know and we have
this with you know
if we have this with our kids too like
how is it that you create the incentive
so it is more complicated than that
because the real answer
is that there is a tension between the
value
of what's in books and the cost of what
is in books and that cost is not simply
the investment of reading them
and so for me i am
keenly aware that when you read a book
especially a book part of the reason
that i may like shorter things better
even if i read a bunch of them and so it
amounts to book length
reading part of the reason that i like
it better is that it's very hard to
resist the mindset of somebody who wrote
a book
if you go through their whole book right
if you take that mindset and then you
abstract it to
a magazine article you still get a
chance to take a tour through their
worldview but you don't take it on
and part of the problem is that the cost
one of the costs of books
is that once you have inhabited
somebody's
mindset it is very hard to remember what
the world looked like before you knew
what it was
and so that has a consequence
a positive one which is that you get the
benefit of what that person knows
and a negative one which is that you've
taken on some of their blind spot
and so uh in any case
the point is it's not that i have
overcome it
it's that i have moved my assessment of
cost and benefit to a place
where you know i mean i do have a very
high threshold if i start reading
something
even if i think there's good stuff in
there but it's not paying back where
it's saying stuff i really think is
wrong right it's very hard for me to
keep going with it
um so so i don't think i've done exactly
what you think
well i feel like you answered the
inverse question
i i now i want to know how you managed
to get any reading done at all
um because there's oh
i mean i don't understand how how the
answer isn't
obvious it's a cost-benefit relationship
and
at the point given your internal model
at the point the benefit exceeds the
cost you're motivated to do it and at
the point you
perceive the cost exceeding the benefits
you stop so that's what you tell your
nine-year-old
no what you tell your nine-year-old i
don't know but um
hang in there your nine-year-old
probably needs to read more
right probably getting them to the
standard of everybody else may not be
doing
them a favor in fact it may be that if
they have the kind of
you know mind that benefits from the
independence were you ever driven to
like um comic novels
like were you driven like i know boys in
particular
tend to get told and like our boys never
had it i don't know if you did but like
boys in particular tend to gravitate
towards things that aren't considered
serious when they're when they're
children and they're supposed to be
learning to read and
they end up they end up looking at um
i don't know like manga and anime anime
and such
and um my sense has been there's some
stuff
in that in that corner of the universe
that i don't
want like once it goes towards porn i
don't want my kids anywhere near it
um but also like if you need to read in
order to get the value out of the thing
why on earth would you tell the children
that they shouldn't be doing that and
they need to pay attention to this
horrible stuff instead right yeah no i
had i had
none of that you had no you did okay i
didn't um and you know my sense is
i took stuff apart instead and that was
very very good for me
um so it's not like again not
not helping the like how do you
encourage a child to read
no no i think it is helping in the
following sense because the parent of a
child who
has an obstacle needs to understand what
problem they're actually trying to solve
and part of the problem is you know what
you absolutely need to be able to read
to do certain
things and the other part of the problem
may be actually
this may be building other kinds of
skills that'll be really useful and i
don't want to
substitute one for the other so maybe
the thing that's missing from this
conversation that you and i have both
said
a lot is um given how that question
sounds
given that it's written in you know
good english by someone who clearly
knows how to read and with a you know a
parent who cares
your son's not going to end up
illiterate and he may read
a lot later than you were hoping for but
if while his peers are learning to read
and even learn to love to read your son
is instead
taking apart things learning how to put
them back together or learning to play
the guitar
or you know any number of other things
there's a
good chance that that's going to be a
deeply held
skill and love that serves him yeah
actually it occurs to me as much as your
encapsulation is exactly right that i do
know the answer to this
awesome i kept trying to get you there
took a little work
sometimes things are like that um
the answer is to read with them
and don't keep moving on to new stuff
moving on to new stuff is what adults do
because
reading is about the content so wait
hold on when you're saying read with
them you're not so i did a lot of
reading to our boys and and actually to
all of us we read
we read the tripod series and we read
harry potter and we had laura ingalls
wilder and we read a lot of a lot of
these big lines madeleine l'engle and
and such um but also you're
that's not what you're talking about
you're talking about
you specifically because i was tearing
my hair out and it wasn't
it wasn't the relationship was not
working
but with our younger son toby you would
have him
read to you yeah and um rather than
push on you would go over and over and
over and over again and i don't think it
was
fun for either of you but it worked no
we made it fun because
he would read something and it wouldn't
be what was on the page
and i would and you recognize that part
of his brain in a way that i was like i
don't even know how you're living like i
don't
know what it is to walk through the
universe like this right and you
recognized it
um yeah i mean it's very it's easier for
me to recognize um
and anyway the point is it's sort of
like so you'd say it back to be like
does that make sense no i wouldn't oh no
are you kidding that's way too
straightforward i would start from the
premise that it did make sense
and then extrapolate to the universe
that that would imply
and that of course turned everything on
its head and you know it was fun
yeah and it worked because as i i
presume your son is the person asking
the question
smart boy who you know no problem with
language and spoken like you know
this kid who the teachers are always
always be like his vocabulary is
extraordinary but ask him to write and
it's illegible like what's going on
not only but you know yeah it's got lots
of issues but right
um but anyway yeah the you know
there it so again the key thing however
you operationalize it
is that adults read as a means to an end
it's about the content whether that's
narrative fiction or
non-fiction and you're trying to learn
about a subject but you read
there's no point in going back unless
like you didn't get it all the first
time
right if your point is to read with
children so that they read better then
the point isn't about the content
it's about the process and so getting
you know going through the same thing
twice the second
pass through something where you've made
error after error and probably didn't
get the content because you were making
so many errors that it made no freaking
sense
right going back to that same thing and
being able to read it all the way
through
out loud so that it makes sense and so
that you're not stumbling about it is
the process
right that's the training to read
process and
um anyway make it fun and don't do it
too much do it enough
but something in there is the is the way
to go excellent
and we haven't answered any questions in
the second hours
we're doing it zach sorry man um
thoughts on the new super street
phenomenon oh
man i think it's great yep it's
uh it's it's really something
um but i feel like you know it's the
first stage in the discovery of a
whole clade of of
gender identities their gender
identities yes it's the first because
the thing is it's one thing
to only be attracted to people sexual
orientation identities
juggling i don't know which is but it is
one thing to be attracted
to only people who were born
into the sex that you're not
right you weren't born into right not
but it's another thing i think cisness
is included in the yeah
it's another thing to have always
been only attracted and then there's yet
another thing in which it's super super
strange
believe extreme no it's ultra super
straight
and then if you believe it is going to
continue that way based on your
experience of
yourself then it would be ultra
super perma straight i believe mm-hmm um
so anyway no what i what i really think
about this
it's so deep it's it's not but um
the uh the thing that i really think is
this this
is a wonderful demonstration of
a premise that all adults should be
well aware of which is so we haven't
said what it is
like super strength yeah probably most
people watching
know but so the in an effort
not to be belittled and silenced i
believe a large number of people who do
not subscribe to the
new uh
what is it even ideology the new version
of trans ideology
um have recognized themselves
as their own they have effectively
i think that there was one guy who made
a video and he said you know what
um just because a guy a straight guy
said i'm not in the dudes who declare
that them that they're
women and that doesn't make me
transphobic what i am is super straight
which means
i'm a dude and i like women who were
born
as girls and okay you need that to be a
gender identity i'm to call that super
straight
not transphobic i'm super straight yeah
what she said
okay so um yeah okay so starting from
there so i was i was trying
really hard not to get cancelled and um
anyway i think i did a very poor job but
yes that
well i think there's nothing in what you
said that was cancelable that's
because it was not parsable and
therefore well actually that's no
protection is it but no it's not
um in any case here's the thing
when you set up rules of the game right
these rules that we have been handed are
rules in which somebody has cheated and
they've placed themselves at advantage
by building
a taxonomy that we have to subscribe to
because the claim is that science has
discovered this thing right
and so very clever for somebody to pick
up
on those rules and say oh yeah okay even
in that rule set
actually you you've handed me exactly
the tool because you've basically said
that anything goes with respect to
a you know a new gender identity
and i got one and so the point is look
yeah it's veils it's it's rawlsy and
veil of ignorance stuff
right don't make any rule you don't want
to live on the wrong side of and so the
fact that somebody made up a bunch of
rules
that they're now going to force us into
with respect to gender identity
um two can play at that game right and
so anyway
especially since they didn't cap the
number of possible gender identities
boy we can we can run wild with this
yeah man so anyway i think uh
i'm i'm very i'm pleased at the
invention of
um super straight as a fancy new gender
identity when really
um a lot of us have not had a name for
what we were for so long
yeah minority position
okay what is the best evidence to prove
that humans are omnivores and not
vegetarian or vegan
i'd argue that a lack of access to meat
led to our ancestors eating less of it
rather than physiology or moral
superiority
well i think the strongest evidence
against strict veganism or vegetarianism
is the orneriness
of strict vegans and vegetarians
um
sorry it's going to be uh the if
to the degree i now can't tell if the
person asking the question
was being ridiculous or just brett as
being ridiculous
um but the implication of your sentence
is that i was definitely being
ridiculous you're included in that
category regardless yeah
so the evidence zach if you just want to
show for a moment is going to be teeth
and gut
um the the the best physical evidence
that we have oh
terrific um so this is uh this is from
the animal diversity web she came out at
university of michigan for which i have
contributed back
back in the day and you see the the
carnassials on these mammalian
carnivores i think this is a
wolf yep um that these are these
shearing teeth these are these are
basically
um premolars and maybe also molars oh
yeah
that have been fused into carnassials
the likes of which you'll find on all
the carnivorous compare that
to so the purpose of those teeth is the
tearing of muscle
go back there yep yeah the ripping apart
of muscle fibers
compared to um that's a classic
herbivore um tooth
which are good at basically
smashing cell walls which plants have in
which animal cells don't
and so you find you find evidence and
dentition differences and then in gut
differences as well where
the longer the gut the more likely and
you know
obviously other things like additional
stomachs and such but the longer the
gulp got the more likely
you are of a higher percentage of plants
in your diet or have an exclusively
plant diet
and um uh we have
frugivores have shortcuts yes yes
leaf um and we have a pretty short
pretty short cut
pretty shortcut and the evidence is
probably much
stronger than our dentition would
suggest because of our tendency to cook
meat which goes back a long way which
means that the need to tear these
fibers apart in their original form is
much reduced so the extent that our
dentition reflects a certain amount of
carnivory is probably
it's a cautious conclusion but the other
thing is
you know we know an awful lot about
hunter-gatherers who
either continue to exist in a few cases
have recently existed
we know what their diets looked like and
we have a lot of fossil and sub-fossil
evidence
from people that we modern science types
didn't get to observe directly and it
all suggests
uh the presence of meat in the diet well
you can do
so fossil and sub-fossil evidence you
can look at nutrition you obviously
can't look at gut
no no it doesn't even necessarily have
to be the individuals
right we have hearths and things like
this there's butchers oh material
evidence
yeah yeah yeah so the the answer is
there's a ton
of evidence of various different kinds
and it all
points to a degree of carnivory right
yeah so that doesn't say anything about
what we should do or maybe it implies
something about what we should do but it
doesn't say it directly but from the
point of view of what we
did evolutionarily this is utterly
unambiguous
did the laws of physics evolve like dna
is specific to earth
if the universe was to start over from a
sort of big bang would physics be
different from now i think this is an
easy question
i do too but it's a fascinating one it's
a great one yeah
and i would say a you haven't answered
it yet
oh you just want the yes or no answer
well we both said i think it's an easy
question
it's an easy question right i would say
you're about to launch into a long
explanation which you don't include the
answer i think
i would say the laws of physics will be
the same
and the simple structures of the
universe
will be the same and biology will evolve
it may or may not be similar it will
have some similarities
no matter where we find it and it may
well have large differences in fact i
believe it would likely have large
differences at the level of the
particulars yeah the physics um
the physics don't evolve is my position
as well
so a you you were human begun so
the a part is properly understood
biology is the extension of a physical
process
and this is going to be a little bit of
speaking and riddles that will have to
be revisited later
but i believe the right way to
understand evolution
is that you have selection before you
ever have anything biological
selection produces all of the patterns
in the universe
right and that process eventually gets
elaborated
into something with heredity which
causes selection
which pre-exists biology to turn into
adaptive evolution which results in
critters
but the point is it's actually a natural
extension of the physics
um and you know the idea that selection
is inherent to biology is wrong so
uh select um selection uh
pre-exists it and you know it continues
through it's the heredity that makes the
adaptation happen
yep genetically you are a fish
are you a stoner memetically
so we could answer this at the
individual level
or at the uh population level and i
would say
individually uh no not anymore
uh i'm not even sure what the question
is asking well uh another
so at the population level yep i
remember that
um on the day that i met bob trivers
uh as i passed as i approached his
office with some
fear because i didn't know what kind of
an amazing and terrifying professor he
might be
um i passed a sign for a talk he had
given the day before
at the big amphitheater in at uc santa
cruz
on the covolution of marijuana and
humans
and i i wasn't there for that talk i
don't know what he said nor have i
pursued this
much but you know if if that's if
there's something
to that uh if if the relationship
between humans and marijuana
is somewhat ancient um
is it you know could we be said to be
memetically stoners
at the population level all right
um does that strike you as a plausible
interpretation of what the question
might be
yep and you were going to head to an
answer or
no okay so then i would say
the problem with that is that it's too
narrow
right we are all very definitely
um descendants of ancestors with
psychedelic experience of one kind or
another it's
too common in cultures to have some
mechanism to get to hallucinations
consciousness hackers consciousness
hackers humans are consciousness hackers
and the culture that doesn't do it is
the exception yeah that proves the right
stoner is too narrow
stoner is too narrow yes so the point is
you're not definitely downstream
of a culture that had a relationship
with marijuana but you're definitely
downstream of a culture that had a
relationship with hallucination
yeah for sure brett you recently talked
about a model for
oh wow i just lost where to go
you got this brett you recently talked
about a model for a shared consciousness
have you read douglas hofstadter's work
on the topic specifically i am a strange
loop but to a lesser extent also girdle
ascherbach
nope probably should yeah i've read
parts of girdle escherbach a long time
ago and i don't know i have a strange
loop and
maybe if it's essay length maybe we
could read it together
um i find him dense i find it hard to
get through his stuff
um but but he's
he's got good ideas so you don't that's
the answer
i don't have good ideas now you tell me
this seemed like the right moment well
this is awkward
will you guys give us a minute can we
have the room can we have the net
next question serotonin dopamine and
other hormonal regulators are always
described as making you feel happy
sad etc is this overly mechanistic is it
possible that feeling happy or sad
produces serotonin and dopamine
um yeah it is totally overly mechanistic
and it's it
it not only potentially gets causation
reversed
sometimes but it also pretends that it's
all proximate and there is no
ultimate explanation for why we have
these states and these hormones in the
first place
yeah and i believe there was a there was
a
study many decades ago about
serotonin and hierarchy
you got it lobsters right but this was
not lobsters this is primates
oh well i've got i mean before long
before jordan wrote his
now previous book i
you keep i'm gonna find like i i used to
include this lobster thing in my
lectures
actually um so i will find it if i can
okay
so what i was going to say and this is
it's been a million years since i've
seen
this work and it's possible i've
misremembered something but
my sense was that serotonin rose with
position in primate hierarchy
and that the interesting thing was if
you gave a low-ranking primate
serotonin if you artificially elevated
serotonin in the primate
the primate would begin to behave as if
they were dominant and of course
the response then has to be if you think
carefully about what has to happen next
if it were true that simply having more
serotonin may put you at a higher place
in the hierarchy then simply you'd make
more serotonin right so what has to
happen
is you get your ass kicked if you start
behaving like you're dominant because
you're full of serotonin right and so
the point is it does suggest
um totally you can you can speak about
this very mechanistically and you'll
miss that
actually it's part of a much more
interesting story
absolutely um so i found the slide that
i would give
in one of my very early animal behavior
lectures when i taught and what behavior
when i was just introducing some of the
interesting stuff going on at various
clades
um so it reads i guess i don't have to
read it out loud because this doesn't go
audio only but i'll read it anyway this
is
among the crustaceans it's not lobsters
it's crayfish
some male crayfish establish dominance
hierarchies through combat
when escaping the loser exhibits a
backwards tail flip behavior that
simultaneously shoots him backwards and
signals his submission to the other
and the winner of the fight exhibits a
forwards tail flip that signals his
dominance
what's new with this research which was
published in 1996 in science
is that both types of tail flip are
prompted by the neurotransmitter
serotonin
depending on social circumstance
serotonin produces opposite behaviors
so you're telling me not only is it not
a rock
and not a rock lobster it's a crayfish
it's a crayfish that's amazing
all right um that's interesting so um
yeah cool and that's from uh early
lecture of yours
yeah that's i i did that every time so
this the opening
slide for this lecture you can show
again zachary
um this is my animal diversity lecture
which usually took
you know eight or nine hours over the
course of many days that i would just go
through
um wow that oh wow
formatting because it's an older version
of because i haven't lectured
in four years now the formatting got off
but um
you know just introducing the various uh
we got a few good mollusks and then i
think
oh we're not quite uh we got arthropods
right up front
yep i miss your lectures
you you do too they were a lot of fun
you invested in building them so
mightily they were
a thing to behold yeah maybe there's
maybe there's another opportunity
at some point to uh to do those again
somehow um the biden administration has
usurped and poisoned the word unity
intentionally what can we do to rebrand
um yeah i agree i
do i cannot help but take this a bit
personally but it's also at some level i
believe
flak over the target i think they
realized
that you know um this is this is
a resonant concept for a reason because
um frankly a lot of us are sick of this
[ __ ]
um so anyway what can we do to rebrand
stay tuned
that's coming it's really important and
uh you know let's put it this way the
the silver lining on the democratic
party
having stolen the word unity is that
they're not any good at it
um yeah they don't seem to be good at it
no they're decidedly terrible yeah
i looked it up for you dr seuss tends to
write an amphibrasic tetrameter or
sometimes anapestic so we actually
um at the beginning of the q a last week
had heard from our moderator that it was
anapestic tetrameter
um which is
i can do it again one two three one two
no i can't do it now
one two three four one two three four
one two three four
um i don't know what amp for brassic or
it could be amphibrachik but it looks
like amphibrasic
means but tell us in the chat maybe zach
will see it and we'll tell us
yeah or i'll look it up that's awesome
and i feel
lame for having thought for even a
moment that it might be iambic
pentameter and
two one two one two one two one two yeah
yeah iambic being one two and then
pentameter
5. there it is there it is
um on the importance of natural dark and
quiet
these places exist closer by see eastern
oregon john day country
absolutely lived here for six years
headed to alaska in two weeks
we'll miss the clear skies and silence
i'm a fellow wildlife biologist in her
50s love the streams
thanks thank you um
you're headed to alaska where you're
going to miss the clear skies and
silence you must be going to anchorage
or some other place
you know it seems like alaska should
have a lot of
um natural dark and quiet yeah a lot of
dark
all at once all at once yeah um good
luck
enjoy alaska um bring socks
that's uh that's what i've heard um
considering your discussion on the
benefits of appreciating nature did the
two of you meditate
good day from australia uh no
not not in so much we don't call it that
i did
um i've mentioned here before i was
lucky enough to spend two weeks
when i was at the end of high school on
a buddhist artist's retreat with tiknot
han and a number
of beat poets from the 60s
and i was like the representative
teenager who had been invited by my
creative writing teacher who was himself
a beat poet
and for those two weeks we did uh tiknot
han let us in three
sitting and one walking meditation every
day um
but i didn't maintain i really didn't
really divide and i
loved that time but i didn't develop the
habit nor have you ever
done so but i think we both find other
ways
of finding
peace from our own thoughts which i'm
sure for those people who are active
meditators will find that
description of what it does or what it
is impossibly naive
but i think you know biking
paddle boarding kayaking like there's a
number of activities that are
active but solitary that provide
that and you know maybe it is a kind of
sometimes for me it is meditative and
maybe because
i did learn about meditation from one of
the greats and one of the kinds of
meditation we were doing
was a walking meditation um
maybe you might actually call it that it
may be part of why i'm so
so resistant and find it so anathema
when
you got me a fancy helmet which would
allow you to speak into my head while i
was biking
it's like i'm going to hurl this thing
into the sea i have no interest in
floats
i promise it could talk to itself then
somewhere else
uh well i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
relitigate that one but i will say with
respect to um
to meditation yeah um uh
i i'm actually in the running for
world's
worst meditator yes i am
really not good at this i mean sometimes
i can do it
not for long periods but six seven
seconds in a row i can
i can really get into some stuff but um
[Music]
yeah i'm absolutely terrible at this
and it uh it drives me crazy i i harbor
no belief that i could get good at it um
you once uh
got us some a uh experimental
uh thing where we got to try sensory
deprivation
tank and separately to sensory
deformation tests
it's not really sensory deprivation if
you're in the same tank yeah you would
have driven me completely crazy
because i put you reported we did at the
same time me completely jason tanks and
you came out of it going like i
barely survived it was like the longest
hour of my life it was
so terrible i do not get this about you
that said that i didn't love it like i
never went back for another one but i
was like okay i see it
i could see getting into it but i'm
certainly not going to force the issue
and you were like
it was it was torture it was torture it
was torture
um but you know yesterday i sat
very calmly and watched wildlife and
listened to the brook
and i had lots of thoughts it was cool
and so i don't know um
yeah the answer would appear to be
no yes no certainly no for brett and um
maybe i could claim that some of my
walks are walking meditations but
honestly not really
yeah um the dog is like why are you
still on
yes oh we got we got we got our elders
here we got our 10 year old kitty and
our eight-year-old dog
it's your birthday tomorrow okay how
about let's do two more questions
i'll mention that after the next
question okay
uh you guys couldn't hear that
presumably but zack says he's going to
point out some
big ticket questions down below that
we'll get to many animals for instance
cats play with their tail
could this be part of the adaptive role
of the tail if not is the relation
completely circumstantial
what's the correct way to think about
this
it's interesting good question yeah i
have training like training and hunting
like early play
yeah but i don't i think the thing is
i've seen
adults flick their tails in adult people
no interestingly
i can't say that they're not doing it
it's just it's very hard to tell
yeah um but i've seen that i'm sure
everyone is now wondering that is an ape
synapomorphy the loss of tail
the loss of the name it's not just us
it's all the apes all the others
absolutely newly directed yep they're
they'd be apes baby apes
gibbons it's the same yes so anyway the
flicking of the tail is a way a parent
could
uh cause a young kitten
to become sensitized to certain kinds of
emotions and things like that i think
that's actually the
two examples that i can think of that i
know to our earlier point
um lion cubs playing with a male's tail
is when you know he puts up with it for
a little while then he's like
yep off me right kid um but i would say
look
tail is a complex phenomenon and the the
right way to think of it
is it does a bunch of things which of
them has primacy which of them drove the
evolution of the thing and then once it
evolved it started doing other things
and so we can ask this question
you know for things like why did music
evolve yes we can establish that it
evolved that it is a
an adaptation and it does many things
right it rallies people to a cause
it brings them together
synchronizes emotions it does lots of
things but the question is what
drove the evolution of the first thing
that crosses the threshold into
qualifying his music
what drove the evolution of tails to the
first thing that we would call
a tail and how does that fit with all of
the things you know in cats for example
we can say
for sure that the tail conveys
information about emotional state
it has a huge impact on the cat's
ability to reorient in the air
and land on its feet i would guess if i
had to guess one i would say that that
parameter the ability to you know to
shift the body by moving the tail in the
opposite direction
so as primacy but
apologies if i missed it but you know
tails are plesiomorphic
boy i'm just using way too many uh
technical terms here today but
tails are plesiomorphic to mammals
meaning that tails are older than
mammals that mammals came into being as
mammals already having tails
right so you know they emerged from
reptiles which had tails and
um frankly probably the you know the
first tetrapod had tails so you got tail
loss in a couple of clades like frogs
and like apes
but um you know tail is really old
really old and so originally it emerges
as a swimming aid right um et cetera so
incidentally i almost use plesiomorphy
to describe selection
in the universe prior to there being
heredity yeah which you're the only
person that would have gotten what i was
talking about but
but i get it now yep yep but anyway yes
your point this moment
yeah me too this has been nice um the uh
your point uh is the correct one which
is in this case we can't say what
drove the evolution of tails in mammals
because nothing drove the evolution of
tails and mammals
tails arrived as mammals were here so in
that but what drove the modification of
tails in
well for instance you know cats using
their tails to write themselves
which um is useful in cats in
in concert with the fact that for
instance they have clavicles
that are that float loose on their
skeleton their clavicles aren't
connected to any other skeleton elements
they're just connected by soft tissue by
ligaments and tendons or
one of the two i never remember the
distinction um
means that they have an ability to do
these you know twisting acrobatics
whereas a dog
um would have less it would be
of less value there yeah um so i don't
what exactly is the character that we're
trying to explain about tails it's not
it's not tails it's something particular
to what for instance
cats can do with tails and you know this
question says for instance cats but it
isn't
specifically about cats you know so i
don't know if for instance
rodents in a burrow having been born to
a litter
um play with tails play with their own
tails or play with their siblings tails
or even once they're out and begin to
forage if they are or or you know or is
it just
um predator species or you know is it
play hunting
um hunting behavior well it's
interesting
surely somebody has done a uh a
review of tail use yeah there's uh
has to be it's melod bats i believe
free-tailed bats
that use their tails to find crevices
that they back into
really yeah um so they use it kind of
like a prehensile
well the thing is in many i think it's
fair to say
most bats the tail is embedded in the
tail membrane the europatagia
um free-tailed bats have their tails
which has been who the molossets are
yeah
have been uh have had their tails freed
from that membrane
leaving them more like mouse tails and
that's a digit oh that's fascinating
i sure hope that turns out to still be
true i remember that you know i never
studied molasses but uh
i i believe that that was the
explanation that's really cool
yeah okay well zach the next two
questions both
look like the next one is a guy who sent
three individual hundred dollar
questions each about
uh gme and amc so you should read them
together well but this one is the one i
was looking at that
was also high yep and then there's a guy
who said hundred dollars with no
chat which is okay when i was pointing
um i'll just i'll read a couple of these
and then you tell me if i missed any
okay
all right do you think that seasonal
affective disorder is actually a
disorder
doesn't it make perfect sense to
conserve energy in a dark cold winter it
seems like the idea of constant work
output despite changes in our
environment is the problem
question mark good one yeah it's really
good
um i would say the quick and dirty
version of this is that
something seasonal that
fits this pattern is almost undoubtedly
adaptive
a pattern in your motivation to go do
versus stay still probably it doesn't
serve us
hold on related to i don't know a couple
weeks ago when i was talking about some
of that moon
that that moon research
the finding that in environments absent
electric lights
uh people will
sometimes
goat i can't remember how it went um
very sometimes go to bed
after the sun sets but very rarely wake
up before the sun rises
and given that that is the case absent
electric lights you would expect
um people to the farther you are from
the equator
the longer you would sleep in the winter
absent electric lights right therefore
constraining ourselves to
a you know eight to five job and a you
know a constant expectation about when
you go to bed and when you wake up
regardless of what's actually going on
astronomically
is a hyper novel problem right and then
imagine
that you project this into a population
is living
near or above the arctic circle then the
point is
it grows incoherent very quickly so
what this says is there's some ancestral
adaptive pattern that ancestral adaptive
pattern is probably irrelevant to people
who can artificially light their
environments and have
effectively unlimited access to food
right so we can be productive
indoors during hours that we might you
know if we had lived in primitive
circumstances
had been better off sleeping to preserve
energy so there's an incoherence
between modernity and the adaptation
problem but then
add on top of that undoubtedly
populations differ in their adaptive
response an equatorial population
shouldn't have seasonal effect of
anything right
so given that and given that we're now
mixing almost at random the point is
well
how much of our predisposition to that
adaptation is genetic that's an open
question
to the extent it's genetic what happens
if two people who come from
different you know latitudes produce
offspring what program do they get is
one of them dominant to the other
and then what do we do with the fact
that your program probably doesn't match
the place you are anyway so
it might just introduce chaos and so yes
all of those things
take the very simple fact of their
likely being an adaptation that is
connected to this
and result in being a horror show uh
in modern times with people uh who don't
know about what they're messing with
messing with this in such a profound way
excellent
next question brett i hope that you are
a part of the gme and amc movement
it's the to die on for all people i
enjoyed you on joe rogan
the fed created a hedge against society
when they repeatedly halted the stocks
and this guy has two other questions
same dollar might you should read them
okay i'll read them us now before you
respond
please give me 15 minutes on your
thoughts on the gme amc saga
more money invested into two stocks than
ever before and we doubled down when the
stock went down 90
and now it physically or mathematically
cannot go down the real deal revolution
please research um our slash gme
and then i have a hundred thousand
dollars in gme and amc
and on february 24th 25th i turned 10k
into a million
dollars about to do it way bigger this
time
you can take the 300 and buy a gme
though i i don't think that i think i
just made it
currently at close-ish to 300 so he's
just saying take my 300
and buy a gmail okay well this is cool
thank you um i would say we are not
invested
that may be dumb i am very much
invested in this idea and the fact
that these markets have become
about the markets are there
to generate value that is supposed to
be recovered as an enhancement on
well-being
that is to say the um the mechanisms of
the market
the mythology of them is about the
production of value and the degree to
which these markets are very much about
something else most of the time and
what i have said is that
really ultimately the only way to profit
in the market
is either through superior insight about
some sort of industry if you can see
where an industry is going before the
other experts can see it you can profit
and then insider information of one kind
or another
and so in effect the hedge funds have
been playing the insider information
game and doing so in a way that is legal
or quasi-legal or who knows and so to
see
a collaborative effort a ground-up
collaborative
effort uh confront that pattern
uh with a similar kind of power and then
to see how many
um apparently unfair
tactics were unleashed on them
because apparently the idea is the
license to bend the rules is extreme
if you come in through one door and it's
disallowed if you come in through
another
was fascinating um so anyway i don't
know what more to say about it
not an expert in it by any stretch of
the imagination but i am fascinated by
the um effectively the revelation of
what our system is built
of by by smart people who were
are not part of the institutional
structure yeah
i will say one more thing about it which
is that we're not invested in it
but our son and producer zachary
is a little bit and three stocks at
sixty dollars each
so zach has three stocks at sixty
dollars each uh
zach you wanna pull up um the page that
has your
your t-shirts on it so zach actually
created a little bit of merchandise
bring that up and um i'm just going to
talk and you can tell me if i'm wrong
while you're pulling it up zach
as i understand it um you say
that and you did uh that you would
invest any profits that you made
in gme and that you would uh i guess
you'd have diamond hands sack is that
right
and yeah the idea is invest 100 of the
profits
from these shirts into gma so obviously
yeah not revenue but profits after
product costs ads etc
yeah a bunch of designs here that people
who know about the gmc
the gme movement specifically will
understand and may
um be very unclear to people who don't
know about it so many of these
sentiments
don't really mean anything unless you
know uh or unless you've spent time in
the
subreddit specifically so you're you're
mic'd right now zach people can hear you
right now they can hear me you are okay
and can people see the url if they were
interested in going
so it's just gme to the moon dot shop um
if you if you're interested in shirts
and 100 of the profits do go
into gme and somewhere i appreciate it
there are hedge fund guys
selling shirts that say gme to the moon
and
back yes
yep they're they're definitely trying to
bring that bring that ship home
yep yes they are yeah um well
gosh a lot a lot more great questions
here and we'll get to a few of them at
the beginning of next week but we
managed to go
way long and it is still
beautiful out for a couple more hours so
i think we're probably going to sign off
and try to
try to get outside for a little bit of
what's remaining of this beautiful day
in the pacific northwest
we thank you as always for
for being here for being interested in
what we have to say
uh encourage you to join us at either of
our patreons
um please subscribe to the channel if
you're not and perhaps the clips channel
as well
uh like this video if you liked it
don't lie um and go ahead and lie
if you're still here now oh yeah that's
a lot of hate watching
if you didn't like it um oh do not
underrate some of our
dedicated detractors
all right i'm not underrating them um
but yeah we'll be here
again next week we'll see you then and i
think i'm gonna uh i'm gonna
go meditate and i'm done
get outside everyone be well
[Music]
[Music]
you